yeah because like like it must it must
be a similar experience what england
went through as well because halloween
to me was like such a always like it
wasn't a holiday it was like it was like
a half a holiday you know it was
something that we acknowledged existed
but no one did anything for halloween
yeah you know um and i i would i would
be interested have you have you spent
halloween in like america or anything
before
uh
i want to i want to i've so far i think
i have i've i've experienced three
fourth of julys in america well yeah i
mean it happens
yeah yeah i already count fourth of july
because every fourth of july for me is
like hungover as [ __ ] because it's
always the last day of ax so i'm just
like oh freedom [ __ ] the scary the
scariest fourth of july experience i had
though was uh was in la and i one of my
friends who lives in la took me to this
like coffee shop that
one of his friends owns in downtown l.a
mind you fireworks are going off all
[ __ ] day right like you wake up to
that [ __ ]
and he was like yeah we should go like
get some coffee uh you know at downtown
l.a first time i've ever been to like
proper downtown l.a right right like
very scary yeah yeah
so i'm there just drinking coffee in
front of my mates coffee shop and you
know people are like doing fireworks out
on the street whatever and i'll never
forget it like the guy the owner of the
coffee shop like comes right up to me
he's like
you know that if it doesn't echo it's a
gunshot
right and i was like
great coffee
i'm gonna go
um
don't feel safe in this city is that how
we started the conversation he started
the conversation i'm like i want you
know i was like i was gonna like warm it
up you know being like how are you how
did you come to run this coffee shop
yeah who are all these people in front
of the soda are they all your no he
literally gave me like a you might get
shot warning
right from the get-go speaking of shots
i think the best holiday is the fact
that we have guy fawkes day
that's a [ __ ] awesome holiday is that
a holiday
is that a proper holiday i'm pretty sure
it's a holiday i don't think it is a
holiday
it's just a day of remembrance it's a
holiday in my heart yeah everything in
the british people it's all they were
celebrating and i think the british
population is hard it's a whole yeah
yeah the fact that we [ __ ] celebrate
some dude trying to blow up our
parliament that's amazing yeah that is
pretty cool so if you haven't
if you haven't heard of guy fawkes he
was a guy who tried to blow up the
british parliament and failed and we
celebrate that by
lighting a [ __ ] ton of fireworks in
celebration
right yeah yeah literally
a country that celebrates a terrorist
act happened on itself like
wait do you guys wear or wear the guy
fawkes masks no no no no no that's like
that thing that happened from the
[ __ ] movie yeah yeah
and [ __ ] warner brothers gets a cut
of every mask sold oh really yeah
they have the rights to that mess wow
bro it's no one wears that mask and
everyone just everyone just goes to the
supermarket buys as much fireworks as
they can and then you all just judge
yourself i can't believe anonymous is
supporting a corporation
i know what's ironic
you're [ __ ] supporting warner
brothers
like that that wasn't a thing when we
were a kid there was no guy fawkes man
no no there wasn't a guy fawkes myself
it was literally it literally started
after v for vendetta yeah that wasn't
the thing so wait he didn't actually
wear that mask no no that was a mask
that was modeled after him basically
right or like a caricature sick face
yeah
i've been lied to i thought he actually
wore that mask what
because my only experience the guy
forces v for vendetta google guy folks
man irl photo irl tinder profile some
[ __ ] all right but i just love the fact
that we celebrate that i just can't like
i don't understand how that came about
like who decided that was going to be
like a thing i don't understand how that
came from i folks real fast oh yeah yeah
okay to be fair if any country
would celebrate that the downfall of its
own uh government other than the french
people yeah these british people now if
that now if that isn't drip i don't know
what it is oh that's the thing man that
is [ __ ] when that guy walks into your
house with a barrel full of explosives
you're almost like go ahead man
he looks so [ __ ] clean man that is
that is a clean yeah okay i can see
where the mask comes from then for sure
oh okay i did not know that there you go
what about easter do you guys celebrate
easter do you anything for easter oh i
just threw it i used to i used to
chocolate yeah yeah yeah so i i did
actually like our family did so like it
would just be like a family gathering
though so where we get like a bunch of
like our cousins and whatnot we didn't
celebrate it at all but like it it
changed from when i was a kid to when i
was an adult so when i was a kid i would
every easter i would go to my grandma's
house and she would hide like a bunch of
like easter egg chocolates yeah
right so me and my sister would like
look for it but now as an adult i do
that for my younger cousins now oh
that's cute so it's like it's kind of
like a a cycle it's but like we're not
like you know religious or anything
about it it's just like oh cool
just getting just get in a circle get in
a circle eat a bunch of [ __ ] eggs eat
a bunch eat a bunch of chocolate block
your arteries and have a good time what
about thai holidays is there any
childhoods
there is um i haven't lived in thailand
for a while so i it's uh i mean
obviously like the king's birthday and
everything like that i'm i'm gonna i'm
i'm going to not say anything in case i
say something yeah i have terrorists i
heard i know there's like time oh i i i
need to talk about thai new year's
[ __ ] hour thai new year's so tiny is
[ __ ] slaps okay so tiny years is like
[ __ ] april it's called songkran
um and basically
okay you said that like so fast
and um and basically so it's like it is
it is tiny years it's when like the
entire calendar flips over and during
our new years it's like the hottest time
of the year right so it's [ __ ] i
think you end up like figuratively there
no no no no no no no no no no no that's
the hardest time
as well right
yeah no so so that's how we celebrate
right is the entire country has a
massive water fight it's [ __ ] insane
it's [ __ ] great it's [ __ ] great i
remember the first time uh first time we
were in tiny years when sydney was there
she was like what's going on i was like
oh [ __ ] it's on so so what we do is uh
you go on the street you buy like the
nearest [ __ ] water gun and you just
start to start shooting strangers and
they shoot you back and you're like so
like people you get shot
sorry you were like are you just shot
basically basically you just seen it
with the bidet
basically completely so
you just started so you just start
firing and it's the only it's the only
socially acceptable time in the world
where you go out on the street and you
better be prepared to get wet because
like
you can't get on the spring break
that actually sounds so [ __ ] fun yeah
so they're like i mean also it is like
pretty dangerous as well i can't get
pretty dangerous because like there are
people even on like [ __ ] motorcycles
you see [ __ ] you see people on
motorcycles and the drivers like just
doing just the drivers driving they have
like a passive he's like doing a
drive-by of people on the street
and i'm just like this could go very
badly like gta like i remember like what
i i remember like one one fond childhood
memory is like we was uh so during 20
years like i went to visit my family and
so we started having a water fight in
our house right and so then
and so and so then we're having a fun
water flight and then my my big my big
cousin rocks up in like a trailer truck
and he goes
get in boys we're gonna start shooting
some people so we just we just like all
would jump in this truck and like drive
around the village and just like start
spraying people and i'm just like dude
that is just like as a kid
as a kid childhood peaks there man i
have two questions one right can you can
you bring in like insane gear like the
nerf collection like the super soaker xl
number two what is the significance of
this day i i understand that we're
squatting each other what's what's going
on what's the point it's a thai new year
and i don't know however what why why
are we squirting each other i don't know
i just assume it's cause it's like the
hottest time of the year i don't
actually know the history behind it but
i assume it's because it's the hottest
time i've ever seen you had a sick
waterfall yeah
you want to just call it
the entire country just wants to cool
the [ __ ] down for like a little bit
before they go back to burning i wish
there was something like that in wales
we just have we have uh
we've been like one day that i know of
which is like we have that in australia
really it's called new year's eve oh
okay
we have like as hot as [ __ ] music we
have uh just like the only welsh holiday
i know that i can remember is just like
the
first of march is decoy deli she's just
saying david's stay what do you do for
that banana just like eat eat leek
what are you heartening me
legit
we legit eat leak we eat leak
i i remember right so here's what we do
here's the pov right pov you're at the
the
the sickest event of the year you could
be at god's water fight i sleep or
picture it you could be in school
singing all the sick hymns huh right and
then you've got your little badge that's
a leak or a daffodil it's one of the two
you attach to the other thing and you
wear red i don't know why i wear red and
then you uh
and sounds like a banging event i don't
know what else we did we used to like
hike
i already know understand the
significance thanks dave i thought i got
a little older i understand it's an
excuse to get a bit drunk which is good
that's that's as you get older that's
just the excuse in every public yeah i i
wish i remembered what this saint did i
i i don't know i just think have to say
something to do with leaks do they have
to do anything i don't know can you just
become a shame did he discover the leak
perhaps he figured out some bomb ass
recipes with the league i don't know
what if we turn this into a suit
hold the phone i don't know actually i
don't i don't really know uh why we do
it but we celebrate that's me and like
most holidays i'm just like a lot of
holidays i'm like i don't know why we do
it but uh
that's most people are getting drunk
yeah that's what's holding us here it's
like what the [ __ ] do i do on ocean day
no one's at the ocean
because it's cold as [ __ ] what is it
called ocean i don't know
two before it but it's like why do we
still celebrate short day when it's not
sure